[Applause]
[Music]
all right guys this Friday is 4/20 but
let's keep it professional
alright you know that day isn't just
about hem anyway we at GameSpot can't
tell you what substances to enjoy but we
can't tell you about some of the dopest
games coming this week so let's do that
first up is Yakuza six the song of life
everyone's favorite thug Kazuma Kiryu
has just spent three years in prison
only to be released and find his adopted
daughter Haruka in a coma after a hit
and run cue the investigation into what
happened in a new life for kiri you in
balancing a criminal past with taking
care of a baby you'll be playing as
Curie you only this time around but you
should still expect a whole bunch of
crazy minigames and side quests Yakuza 6
finally releases on ps4 outside of Japan
on Tuesday April 17th
you know if you are getting the munchies
this week that don't starve mega pack
might just make you hungrier but at
least Xbox one owners can finally pick
up this awesome bundle which packs in
the original don't starve that don't
starve together co-op DLC and the reign
of giants and chipwrecked expansions
that means tons of options for you know
not starving that's coming Tuesday the
17th Nintendo switch is getting a port
of its own this week with breaks are for
losers this recent game is all about
old-school top-down arcade speed you can
race around the track legitimately or
pick up a powerup and screw over your
opponents you can also compete for top
scores and Time Attack or go for a
flawless run in perfect race mode breaks
are for losers revs on to switch on
Thursday the 19th the switch is also
getting really experimental on 420
Nintendo lab Oh takes your console in a
crazy new direction with cardboard
peripherals you can build yourself
called toy cons there are included
minigames and blueprints for you to play
around with but you can also build your
own contraptions and program all sorts
of controller functions with the games
toy con garage you can pick up the
variety kit for 70 bucks or 60 pounds or
the robot kit for $10 more but they both
drop on Friday the 20th and if you have
further questions you can check out a
preview from yours truly that goes into
the pros and cons of this unique idea
now let's go the total opposite of
kid-friendly with God of War Kratos has
moved north and now he has a family his
son at Reyes will accompany him on this
journey which sees the Spartan battling
monsters and gods from Norse mythology
he's also traded the blades of chaos for
a battle ax and the game in general is
much more open than the rest of the
series with bigger areas to explore and
optional bosses to take down god of war
gets reimagined on ps4 on Friday the
20th and those are some of the hottest
games we'll be playing this week as
always remember that release dates are
based on retailer listings and are
subject to change thanks for watching
guys and I'll be back with one more
batch of April games next Sunday